so the iphone three-point OB de comes
out this summer and you can't have it
yet luckily we have an unknown developer
and with us here today who's gonna show
you a bit of how the operating system
works some of the main highlight
features there's the copy and paste
there's the multimedia text messaging
and finally the live search all these
functions were a little bit buggy since
this is a beta that's just a given hey
don't don't know Twitter this with a
copy paste we were able to highlight a
block of text once you DoubleTap the
block of text it creates to drag points
in the corners and you're able to drag
those points to highlight whatever text
that you want and then you can double
tap to hit copy and we're going to go
over to the notes application and try to
paste that block block of text there are
some problems doing this it was a little
bit slow because it's you know just
buggy and we had to try a couple times
he double tapped and it brought up this
box that said paste once we finally were
able to do that we hit paste and sure
enough the the text showed up and
secondly are tall and attractive and
master individual was able to walk us
through multimedia messaging we had some
problems there we try to take a photo
and send them as a message and the the
photo the camera kept crashing but we
were able to with with messaging we were
able to copy and paste some text and
choose a photo in our library and send
it successfully that way so thirdly he
was able to perform a live search
function and that was a system-wide
search kind of like the spotlight on Mac
OS 10 he started typing f 00 and as you
could see it showed some applications
and some entries containing those
letters and yeah that's pretty cool we
will I look forward to using that too
because right now the iphone has zero
search capabilities which seems pretty
primitive so um I think those that that
about covers it right
I can do this thank you okay think of
something happy sees me on